it's all about being in the in-crowd and
I've been reflecting about this you know
sociologies would have a field day about
it yeah at Bell Labs they of course were
the computing science research section
they could afford their own computers
but I think even there they liked the
idea that it was their computer and it
wasn't the computing centers computer
although there was one let me go way
back to the 60s and 70s when multi user
computing came on the scene even here at
Naughty and it was batch it was cards
and paper tape in those days that we
could but of course the university had
to make quite sure that your user name
reflected a fair bit about you so they
could categorize you I remember I think
I was p m z DF b p pure science faculty
m mathematics department said don't ask
me why member of academic staff DF d six
characters we were all like that but
when we could afford our first unis
computer we thought we can be like Bell
Labs I could be just DF be wearing with
the in-crowd we've got our own computer
and it's all ours I'm sure that was an
awful lot of what was being reflected in
that if you say BW k way over 90% of a
computer science audience will tell you
who that person is
but I've checked back with Brian about
this and I said well was it always
initials because I know in North America
you know first name middle initial
surname is very common he said well
almost always
and I said well what about Ken Thompson
then he's kin isn't he and it was more
or less Davey you going to tell Ken he
can't be Ken no apparently Ken because
he was so early on was on multix not
just on unix and absolutely ground zero
multi-user system and which he was
helping to design he was Ken and that
was allowed you see so I think the rule
came about that if you've got a short
first name
then fine that might be used as well so
that was part of the whole thinking
behind all this and I guess the next
question I asked Brian because I know
how it evolved here was were you allowed
to have more than three letters and so
yeah yeah there's a guy I think surname
was chesaning you know Chaz
no problem you know and so oh and Rob
Pike I think was allowed to be robbed
yes a it and I said well did anybody
pull rank and say I'm seen here I want
that and again according to Brian no no
it was first-come first-served if you
got the if you got the acronym then that
was yours
so it started me off I'm thinking well
if I'd only been fortunate enough to
stay longer at Bell Labs in my brief
visit in 1986 I didn't stay long enough
but if I could only have had a user name
could I have been DFB at Bell Labs the
answer is yes but here's the sad story
doctor heartbleed he's SRB so I said to
Brian how about Srbija balance sorry
Steve he said it's gone already
Steve born inventor of the Bourne shell
we'd have had to find something else
when you think about it you can see some
of the perils and pitfalls and this what
about if two people have very nearly the
same three-letter codes but not quite
and you accidentally send the wrong
email to the wrong person that has
happened to me with Steve a few times in
fact the two Steve's that are a bit
ambiguous I've gotten both on computer
file
Steve Bagley is SRB Steve Benford of
blogging guitar fame is SDB and I have
from time to time had a baffled visits
from SDB saying what on earth do I know
about document engineering or something
like this the virtue was of these very
simple three-letter names
was it going to remember your back in
the days of dumb terminals here pretty
well keyboard character-driven terminals
what you type is what you get it could
have also completed but that would have
been in its infancy the idea of auto
completion and yes then you can click on
it no that had to come in the future
that came in with graphics terminals
later UNIX windows Mac's all that so
there you are out in the visiting bell
labs you've got a dumb terminal you want
to send somebody any an email being able
to type whatever you would be as they
are at something easy to type that
mattered a lot I still routinely type
three-letter acronyms to get through to
people on email unless I'm replying to
something of course they're man it then
that's all automated it's not just
computer scientists although we're
probably the worst about it but as you
know in high school teaching in in any
organization where somebody's trying to
say who's in charge of this item on the
agenda who's the person responsible
rather than writing a full name you'll
often just put three initials at the
bottom again it's in the in-crowd we
board members know who each other are
and ABC is in charge of this particular
matter
when we come to doing our grading sheets
our mark sheets here every year and we
look at each student's individual
performance there's always a little bit
added on in the corner the three-letter
log in name of the academic members
stuff responsible for that student and
that helps you normally what happens if
you've got a initials that don't really
let's say they're not they're not
something you want to be known as oh yes
they're there if there is some rude
examples of this but let's try one that
isn't made as well um I know that many
of the viewers here are very familiar
with things like github now I know what
it means and I wondered well is there
some other kind of more universal
meaning of
get them that and I looked it up and it
says on Wikipedia no less that get is a
UK inspired prefix for a person's just
very very annoying which is true I don't
think there's any other meaning behind
to get in get up other than that so you
know somebody called Joe George
Ian Taylor might not like having the
three-letter acronym get the other only
other thing I think we haven't covered
is what happens with people as have only
got two initials yeah now apparently at
Bell Labs ground tells me that Tom Duff
who is really famous fabulous computer
graphics guy and everybody the inventor
of Duff's device look it up I might even
do a separate video on that at some
stage yeah Tom Duff so famous you just
allowed to be Gd now that's amazed me
cuz my dad and we can refer back to
YouTube videos again when he was with
his type X machine out in the field he
had to have US Air Force accreditation
because he was reporting a cyber clock
to the US Air Force he got his
documentation you know what it said at
the top
Frank nmi Brailsford so what does nmi
stand for and no middle initial yes so
you know I'm surprised to find that tom
Duff has no middle initial I'm not
saying it's quite unique in North
America but there we go I would have
thought perhaps lots of systems required
that had to be this of the same format
yes again you know and asking Brian
about this as background to all of this
he points out that there was a sort of
feeling that maybe not going beyond four
would be a good thing because again it's
a thing where we hope to get on onto
another videos there were some weird
word lengths in early computers and for
example I remember that on the ICL
series computers there were six bit
characters not 8-bit characters and
24-bit integer words so four characters
for six to 24 would fit into one word on
a computer like that
I think he said similarly one of the
machines he was on it was fine to have
up to six characters it was all
efficient because 660 36 it was a 36 bit
machine so those kind of considerations
because we're computer scientists were
background factors as well it should be
such a quiz right just a little quiz who
can be the first commenter not to say
first but to tell you Shawn the answer
the following question who is de que any
clues is it a bit um I don't want to
give too many clothes except says a
computer scientist yes and a second and
rather harder one another very famous
computer scientist was at Bell Labs but
he's no longer there but he's very
famous and it's a he his acronym at Bell
Labs was a V a and it's not female it's
male it's not a surname he was a VA
who's that good
I hope these aren't just available on
Google and people will just go hard them
I do there might be that definite come
went up after the talk introduced
himself it was the first time he met
Freddie since he was threatened with
instant death I think Freddie's
wonderful handwriting you know what